but you know what i like about san fran
and the reason i picked this city to do
my specials because
of all the major cities in america
somehow people get along here better
than anywhere else i've seen in the
country
that's right
right
and i always admire saying fran for that
and today i've realized how you did it
put all the [__] on the other side of
that bridge
there's nothing she ain't happy on that
side
[Applause]
if you leave san francisco like bye
thanks for coming to san francisco
come back in april we're having a sale
on birkenstocks
as soon as you get to the other side
welcome to oakland [__]
[Applause]
quick
[Music]
you know that's my grand my grandmother
used to sing that when she cleaning up
that's a negro spiritual
black work song
[Music]
everybody know about that
i know see white people you guys might
whistle when you work
you dig
but that's how you can tell what kind of
work we're actually doing
[Music]
[Applause]
i study that kind of [__]
i do anything that has to do with race i
read a little here see a little there
and i travel that's always good
traveling has made me a
a racism connoisseur if you will
you know it's different from region to
region
anyone ever been down south
so you guys know what i'm talking about
and the racism down there
is just [__] nice
perfect
it's due to a perfection
it's comfortable it's out in the open
there are no secrets in mississippi
everybody knows the deal
morning [__] morning sir
[Applause]
not up here
you hit the big cities man it's
different it's always a secret
and we should do like them we should
keep our [__] on open then a little i
mean with limits
you don't want to say whatever comes to
your mind it might be a little much
white dude be walking down the street
man in this business and
brother walk up to him hello
you right oppressor you
slave master rapist of africa
why hello my big lip spear chucking
friend
touche hunky
so whitey what did you do today huh
oppressing new land to make the people
there christians against their will
what did you do fellow
burn those big black lips on a crack
pipe as you missed your job interview
[Applause]
easy whitey you're cutting deep
now this chitchat has got me thirsty
[Music]
if you will excuse me for a moment i'm
gonna go to the korean store and get
something to drink
hello
you slanted at ruining the economy in
our neighborhood by opening stores and
taking the money out the community cheek
wow
good
afternoon y'all browse around but never
buy anything suspicious
after a while that might be too much
i got a lot of things to talk about
tonight first of all
i've stopped smoking weed
with black people you didn't let me
finish [__] god damn i'm sorry
black people to break the news so
publicly but i can't smoke with you
time i smoke weed with my black friends
all you talk about
is your trials and tribulations
i'm sick of that [__] i got my own
problems against a waste of weed i'm
smoking weed to run away from my
problems not taking on yours
now on i smoke weed exclusively with
white people
[Music]
calm down [__] you win by
default
[Applause]
you got good weed conversation
all white people talk about when they
get high
is other times that they got hacked
i can listen to that [__] all night dude
remember at frank's last week it's
[__] smashed man
and catalogs everything they drink two
shots of jaeger
tequila
four bong hits men
beer
cheeseburger
that [__] is great the only bad part is
you cannot
pass out around white people
every time white dudes
pass out around each other they always
do some borderline gay [__] when the
guy's asleep
frank fell asleep so we like stuck a
carrot in his ass and
put shaving cream on his balls like
why [__] why'd you do that to a
friend of yours they trusted you enough
to sleep around you gonna put a carrot
in his ass that is that nice
[Applause]
i tell you right now if i put a carrot
in a black dude that [__] will kill you
when he wakes up for some [__] like that
that is an automatic
death sentence on the street it's a wrap
for you i'm going to kill that
[__]
[Applause]
i thought y'all was friends baby
what happened
i i fell asleep at this house right we
was drinking and i fell asleep to this
house and and while i was sleeping right
i'm just gonna kill that [__]
all right that's all you need to know
[__] carrots
it was one of my first
white friends like in my life man
good dude too he moved to silver spring
from utah of all places
i guess his family was affiliated with
that mormon church they got down there
and
made him used to hang out and one day i
was at his house we were just hanging
out and timmy says dave
why don't you stay for dinner tonight i
said oh man i'd love to but i can't
if i'm not home before dark my mother
will kill me
that was a lie
my mother had several jobs i hadn't seen
her like three or four days
and the only reason i lied to timmy was
because at that point in my life it was
my experience
that white dinner wasn't delicious
[Applause]
i'd rather go home and fry some bologna
or some [__] like that
[Applause]
but then old timmy threw me a curve ball
i wasn't expecting he said oh it's too
bad you can't stay dave because um
mama
made stove top stuffing
i said what the [__] stove top
oh hold on [__] let me make some phone
calls real quick
i had seen that commercial so many times
i dreamt of getting my hands on some of
that stovetop stuffing
and finally i met a [__] that
actually had a box of stovetop in the
house i couldn't miss this opportunity
so i pretended to call my mother
and then i came back and i said timmy
timmy you're not going to believe this
great news mom said i can stay and he
said fantastic he said why don't you
come with me and we'll help set the
table and then we can say the blessing i
had no
interest in setting this motherfucker's
table or saying these crazy ass mormon
prayers
i just wanted that god damn stuffing
so i told him i said you know what i'd
love to help but let me go wash my hands
first my plan was simple
wash my hands slowly and by the time i'm
done the table will be set the blessing
will be said and all that there will be
left to do
is eat
i went to the bathroom
i wash my hands very slowly i must have
been in there for about 10 minutes
and suddenly
one of his mothers came to the door
[Applause]
she was like hi
david right
i said yes ma'am
she said timmy tells me that you're
planning on staying for dinner
i said i hope that's not a problem ma'am
she says no it's no problem in fact we'd
love to have you it's just that we
weren't expecting company and i'm afraid
there's not enough
stove top stuffing
for everybody
so i kicked her in the
bam
ladies and gentlemen
i told you i'm dope [__]
i told you i was gonna say and you still
didn't see it coming
and that's why i make the big bucks
people only see the surface
they see the division in our foods
it's because i eat chicken and
watermelon
they think that that's something wrong
with millions let me tell you something
if you don't like chicken or watermelon
something is wrong with you [__]
there's something wrong with you where
are all these people that don't like
chicken and watermelon
i'm sick of hearing about how bad it is
it's great
i'm waiting for chicken to approach me
to do a commercial [__] i will i'll do
it for free chicken
least i can do
they make fun of letting people for
eating uh what y'all eat beans
rice
corn
listen that's not a reason to hate a
[__] all right it's funny but
it's not a reason to hate
the only reason these things are even an
issue is because
nobody knows what white people eat
you've been very good at keeping that
[__] a secret amongst yourselves
i study white people you don't know that
i'm writing the paper on you
not even for school [__] just to do it
just get doing this independent research
i'm spending my money that's why i'm
working so hard
i follow you around grocery stores they
freak out i just try to peek in the car
they always seem get away from my car
[__] what are you looking at
chicken and giblets are over there
you must be lost
these are vegetables
i know what you drink
see how quiet it got
grape juice surprise [__] you
didn't know i knew about grape juice did
you oh don't play dumb with me look at
what
a lot of black people don't have the
privilege of knowing about grape juice
because they
have great drink it's not the same
formula that you get
ain't no vitamins in that [__]
you might have one of your black friends
over todd todd
would you care for a glass of grape
juice what
[__] what the [__] is juice
i want some grape drink baby
oh it's purple
i don't think i know what a grape drink
is what
i have some apple juice if you want what
the [__] is juice
i want some apple drink
scream
remember that commercial for sunny
delight when all the kids run in from
outside playing they all run to the
fridge
all right
i got some purple stuff some sunny d as
soon as i say sunny